[Musique]
alors je il nous reste quatre émissions
ouais tu le sais et après c'est toi
d'ailleurs qui va prendre la suite un
dès lundi prochain
et c'était le moment de faire un peu le
bilan parce qu'on fera les 50 meilleures
images vendredi avec un prime time qui
démarre à 10 heures à 19 heures ça va
durer toute la soirée aura des surprises
des trucs dont je vous le dise avec la
folie on va faire la fête partout mais
quand je dis partout ça va être partout
il y aura même une fan zone qu'on va
mettre en place je vous dis si si on
vous attendra je vous le dis on va
mettre une fan zone où qui pourra
regarder l'émission où dort à même des
gens qui viendront chanter la folie
ferrer la folie la folie de la volaille
et on vous avait demandé j'ai demandé
aux gens ce qu'ils voulaient revoir déjà
dès aujourd'hui puisque ya tellement de
séquences qu'on pourra pas tout faire
vendredi
ils m'ont dit qu'ils aimeraient bien
pouvoir des moments de solitude donc on
s'est dit on dans les moments de
solitude de tpm paya notamment quand
vous avez fait des imitations cette
année et julien je crois que vous en
avez choisi nh
c'est quand on s'appelle convaincre on
s'est mis à hurler wen tribune et qu'on
avait demandé à gilles de fer limitation
c'est ça ouais c'est plus alors là c'est
une émission qui va démarrer par une
extrême tristesse désespérante après une
énorme cela avec nous qui vient de porto
rico il va dire c'est ça la télé
française
regardez c'est gilles verdez et il a
imité mac l'autorité notre président au
camembert non regardez pas trop criez
pas trop crié à ma fille j'ai loin pour
une fois on n'a pas trop crié
au bras
très petite à soir après soir
oui
ouvrant les comptes used un garçon un
problème effectivement donc voilà c'est
de l'eau chaude julien crise tessin est
mon frère où ils pas tous à lui son 3e
rima qui est avec aujourd'hui en temps
en temps que potes en voilà c'est mon
pote voilà il est bien là tu y arrives à
déployer un petit cadeau pour moi je
crois valérie bénaïm vous avez choisi
quel moment de solitude vont en
imitation on va regarder ailleurs je
suis resté sur gildas encore mary massy
parce qu'il a aussi le don de savoir
imiter les animaux ah oui notamment
l'otarie encore triste et cardiologie
l'otarie je saisis c'est un coup mais
c'est pas beau du tout à l'arrivée si
vous nous regardez
[Applaudissements]
d'affaires de vous oui on va pas tout
les faire je crois jean-michel moi
c'était une fois on faisait surnommer
toc toc que tu es sont pitoyables à une
fois c'était valérie ma chère mal eric
haïk c'était qui avait voulu imiter
astérix est ce que tu es sûr drôle c'est
qu'à l'avant l'envoyer pour une fois
avec une moustache différente d'une
autre couleur que d'habitude c'était ça
qui voit tout cas c'est toujours le même
humour c'est parti tout à fait une
petite imitation astérix bien sûr
parfois sur magic par toutatis bits des
roma sur la mer venez avec moi quand
elle valait le fer d'or venait que moi
même année le faire dehors
vous savez 8 es quelqu'un vous luiz ou
parce que vous savez faire une imitation
d'un animal ou d'une personne non non je
suis vraiment nul c'est un nul en
dégustation j'aimerais bien vous avez un
bac sommes nous un très bon non plus je
vous laisse pas maxime gagné oui alors
on est mais vous savez que ça lui va
bien comme ça l'a finalement j'adore ce
nouveau look j'étais un petit peu
dubitative but hâtif et finalement ça y
est je l'acceptent je suis pas mal cerné
acceptez-vous je m'accepte tu accepté
toutes ces petites j'accepte aussi une
vidéo que j'ai trouvé d abel j'adore
compter les mythes patrick sébastien qui
compte a fait tourner les serviettes
c'était en janvier dernier c'était drôle
et c'est mais pourquoi quand on met la
télé sur nous on a l'impression qu'on
est retombé face à lyon n'a rien c'est
en 1922
regardez lisa veulent c'est génial
janvier s party journée aller isabelle
morini bosc
si le vizir génial mais c'est un mélo la
michael jackson et madonna a tourné sa
mère fait leur bête mais c'est pas mal
trouvé ça y est
[Rires]
on sent que le problème c'est d'arriver
à parler en tournant la main elle arrive
pas pour les 200 ans
vous avez choisi quad et moi j'ai choisi
valérie juste en vallée du rhône un
combat sur les versions patrick beissel
mais justement rien volé vraiment qu'on
la regarde
oui c'est avec sa médaille à abu
attention aux réponses ou retrouveront à
bachir bah vous le dites on patrick
sébastien c'est que d'amour et voisines
y aille vite les i
les vols réveille toi là-bas je t'aimais
bien vous jugent ils alors moi j'adore
les frères bogdanoff
ah oui et j'avais hurler de rire vous
avez le même on a beaucoup de banques
dont les adore et c'est que vous êtes
des personnages la plupart cyclo y est
donc en décembre dernier il avait parlé
avec l'accent du sud ouest est génial
regardons d'abord et que ça peut te
[ __ ] à faire chier on me parlait d'une
avance um avec l'accent du sud yg ans
allez-y des machines qui fait des
patates et bonbons
c'est quoi la manche aller des bouchons
dans les oreilles non
en cas d'accord le pire on ne sait pas
qui limite on sait pas qu'ils imitent à
décoller les salles devraient juste pour
moi j'ai la personne qui est en train de
traduire depuis quand même dix minutes m
c'est vrai que la pole à la pauvre ça va
ça se passe bien les gens tentent tous
parfaitement vente au bar vainement et
comment dit on de même bien battu par
l'espagnol l'a fait kiffer espagnol il
est beau ah ouais il permet aux aidants
super méchante hyper bien y est parvenu
en plus c'est qu'ils sont fils son père
annoncé qu'ils défendent j'y suis arrivé
parce que n le sel elle ne sort qu'avec
des fils de personne polarité personas
ramos ouais ok vraiment à mon père
bannon donc non voilà géraldine maillet
une vidéo que j'ai adoré alors vous
savez dans la littéraire salaires en
cause l eau cette fois c'est fou tout
faux dans la littérature ou dans le
cinéma il n'y a jamais de zéro son
némésis bien sûr les genesis avec eux
police ni mais il est quoi la déesse de
la juste colère en fait de la vengeance
vous saviez ça l'est mais this fall
assure des visites méhari voilà et matin
fait penser à une sorte de fausse
conversation entre vous et benjamins à
propos d'un prime que arthur n'avait pas
me lancer vous avez compris la série
lorraine
sans déconner elle est partie de nemesis
et à l'arrivée way en chantier école on
va regarder des gros jeux d'hier après
ouais c'est ça merci la très belle aude
s est pas mal là ça vous plaît oui
auriez vous avez des menus bedous
alors je facture ont fait matin we want
me que je t'ai pas mais ça ne me choque
bah oui c'est vrai je ne dis pas ce que
je ne comprends pas pourquoi quand on
fêter les 50 ans de télévision on
boycotte totalement la télé réalité
ouais mais la passion friche cliniques
ont fait rire d'émotion
voilà ouais ça c'est dead c'est
exactement ce qu'il m'a dit ouais c'est
ça je suis témoin
[Rires]
merci ça va merci si on embrasse les
maisons ce qui le regarde hashtag
nemesis bout alors alors oui c'était une
imitation de vous t'as ton dos et que
vous imitez plutôt vous avez une
imitation de nicolas sarkozy le premier
alors aux pompeys et je vais raconter
c'est l'ex du fils de nicolas sarkozy
l'ancien président a lancé un ancien
mois dans un des deux présidents de
coller c'est nicolas sarkozy
alors oui messieurs elle c'était là la
meuf de son fils
après les sorties avec eux oui la fille
de margaret thatcher
c'est vrai hélas les sur le fils poutine
[Rires]
soumettrait
le cache pas
c'était ma première émission pour me
mettre dans le bain franchement vous
avez assuré j'avais envie de revoir
cette petite zemit l'autobronzant mais
c'est incroyable vous avez montré hier
j'ai vu tout à l'heure j'ai vu chez cuit
du dit ami l'autobronzant vous avez sur
ses cuisses vous avez vu que c'était sûr
de mes mollets il a vu jamie de tombes
roseraie mais c'est normal parce qu'elle
avait une tache de naissance ou vers un
problème mais je vous le dis voilà les
mâles et allez ça vous va très bien la
balle et regardez c'est compris un
concer compris c'est compris et capucine
super content ici les photos je peux
vous dire que quand elle vient à la
maison c'est la première levée pour
préparer ma chicorée merci
on va revenir sur cas plus sur l'avenir
de capucine anna va nous dire ah tout
dans un instant bien entendu et si vous
trouvez qu'elle dit une connerie bien
sûr buzzer mais est parti avant même
temps vous avait-il goutte chez eux dans
dans the voice
si et si et si et si et si la bougie hot
chilli elway regardez j'ai les images
arf de dix magistrats ou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c
ouais été coach aussi we were da lua
c'était pour montrer des lycées
exactement pareil parce que je suis
obligé de faire mais comment le même
habillage exactement les mêmes sièges
il ya juste moi je vous dis il ya un an
je crois que c'est en mongolie en fait
où les mecs je vous jure que c'est vrai
je crois qu'il tourne avec des chaises
de bureau aura tête de ma mère georges
leekens au casa je me demande et parce
que ils sont très bien passées sur les
fauteuils de bureau là bas benjamin
castaldi on va revenir sur les
imitations de gil courtemanche a oui à
6,6 et cette fois ci c'est tombé sur la
pop céline dion et là vous allez voir
c'est un véritable massacre s'était
passé par bonjour je viens de jouer je
suis heureux d'être avec vous ce soir
jean marc généreux
non c'est pas trouvé c'est qu' aux
attentes et une théorie baril comment
elle fait oui bravo mme dion voilà c'est
céline dion ça bien sûr ah ouais
d'accord elle a pris un coup de pelle
ans
[Rires]
oui
et c'est tout cas ça fait du bien au
barça on verra des séquences à toute la
semaine et puis bien sûr vendredi ça va
se terminer en apothéose en a plein de
choses à faire parce qu'on va parler du
carton du jour ce qui s'est passé hier à
la télé l'amour est dans le pré se love
is in de prairies dino amour est dans le
pré